hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
welcome to the hackintosh pro project
par 4 let's go so this video is number 4
in this series in case you missed it
there are the first three parts in the
last video we took basically a
screwdriver and turned a whole bunch of
parts into an actual computer so in this
video we're basically going to go over
the surprisingly simple steps in order
to create a hackintosh pro out of the
computer we just made so there's already
a pretty general outline out there for
installing Mac OS 10 on non-apple
hardware so the links below this video
right below the like button on this
video are pure gold this is probably the
most important link heavy description
you will see on mkbhd video Tony Mac x86
is probably the most important one that
is sort of the renowned or well-known
hub of all things hackintosh and that is
where you will find written instructions
parts lists compatibility tips tricks
all sorts of things related to
hackintosh customization and build tips
so if you have any questions about
hackintosh definitely feel free to check
out their forums check out you know if
you google something about a hackintosh
the first link is probably going to be a
Tony Mac x86 comm link so Tony Mac x86
is a great resource and one particular
link in the description below will be
pretty much the written instructions for
everything I'm about to describe to you
that makes this hackintosh Pro different
from other hackintosh so for the
skeleton of this process there are only
two things you really actually need to
get this done once you build your
hackintosh number one is a computer
that's already running some version of
Mac OS 10 you need have access to the
App Store on that computer so that you
can download Mac OS 10 mountain lion and
number two is one of these guys this is
a flash drive you're going to need a
flash drive a USB flash drive of 8
gigabytes or larger and this is going to
be your installed drive this is going to
be the magical little key that lets you
install mac OS 10 on your new computer
at the hackintosh so to start with the
hackintosh build you're going to need to
prepare this USB key and in order to do
that we're going to go ahead and head
into number one the actual Mac and go
into Disk Utility and basically format
this completely so you're going to have
to erase it you're going to use gyd
partition into one hard drive you can
name it whatever you want
and basically just format it to erase it
clean then you're going to use a piece
of software that is also linked danville
but on this video called Yuna Beast and
Yuna beast is going to be basically what
makes this your installer drive you're
going to use Yuna beast to look at your
copy of Matt goes ten mountain line and
install it on your flash drive it'll
take a few minutes but basically one
unit beast is done your USB key is now
the magic key that's now the Installer
so now that this is bootable when your
hackintosh is done being built plug it
into one of the USB 2 ports and boot her
up and cross your fingers because if you
built everything correctly hopefully
nothing blows up or explodes and hold
down whatever key gets you into your
motherboards bios so for my board it got
me into UEFI by pressing the Delete key
sore some other more motherboards it's
the f12 key or f4 or something whatever
your motherboard says to get into your
BIOS hold that down and what you want to
do is boot for the first time into that
USB Drive when you put into it hopefully
you'll get into the Mac os10 installer
this is when you format your SSDs which
is what I have in my building you format
one of your SSDs and install mountain
lion on that now you'll be done booting
and you will actually get into Mac OS 10
with the USB key still plugged in but
you are not done it's definitely not
done yet the second piece of software
you'll need is called multi beast and if
you don't have it on that computer you
probably won't obviously you can use
another flash drive to download it and
then install it by plugging it into the
new hackintosh basically multi beast is
those want to give you your your boot
loaders your drivers your basically
everything that you need to get
everything working without your magic
key so right now you can only boot with
the magic key you use multi beast you
have to take a certain number of
settings and I'll have my settings right
here so if you guys want to see which
ones that I used that was just for my
specific set of parts it is different
for every single set of parts but it
mostly depends on your motherboard and
your graphics this sort of combinations
I will check marks will determine what
you tick so once you tick what you need
in multi beast you will install multi
beast on your new SSD with hackintosh
and then you'll be done so then you can
restart unplug your magic key and you'll
be able to reboot into Mac OS 10 and I
guess then at that point you are
officially on a hackintosh I would
probably rate my steps about a 5 out of
10 for difficulty some things I probably
rebooted mine about
forty times to get the the colonel flags
exactly right and get exactly what I
needed for it to boot without me having
to interrupt so now when I turn on my
hackintosh I press the power button and
it boots all the way up and I don't have
to press anything so you're going to
have to get to adjust and fiddle with
your settings but again the Tony Mac x86
forms are brilliant for finding the
exact settings you need for your
combination of parts but that's
basically what I did and the kernel
flags ended up working perfectly and now
I can boot and it's just working now
there are two empty SSDs still on this
akatosh remember we installed three SSDs
in there we only installed Mac OS 10 on
one of them this is because we have the
other two SSDs for our raid 0 array so I
again use the set of written
instructions down below right below this
video and that is what allowed me to set
up basically cloning that brand new
fresh OS 10 install and stripe it across
a raid 0 array on the other two SSDs and
this is what's going to give you blazing
fast read speeds blazing fast write
speeds insanely snappy performance I
already noticed a difference between my
Mac Pro and the hackintosh Pro but
that's the next video so make sure you
guys are ready for that but basically
it's going to give you insanely fast
speeds and especially for video editing
when you're working with video which is
really large files live you're going to
be able to want to work in a raid array
that's going to give you a much better
performance first thing I installed
though was Google Chrome I literally as
soon as I got into the raid 0 array for
the first time I went into Safari and
went to google.com slash Chrome and then
started working from there so after I
install that I installed
Nvidia's CUDA drivers and basically what
these allow you to do is use the
insanely powerful processing cores on
the graphics car the GTX 670 overclocked
Edition that I have in this build to
offset some of the tasks that Adobe
Premiere and After Effects loved so much
so the Adobe programs will look at those
1344 cuda cores on that graphics card
and be able to offset a ton of those
tasks onto the graphics card from the
CPU so the six core CPU won't have to
work a sorry even though it's still a
workhorse and a beast of a CPU and then
all these things will be working really
quickly through the 32 gigs of ram and
the cuda cores on the graphics card
those instructions to enable in cuda are
also in the links below telling you this
is golden down there golden right below
the like button but basically once you
get everything set once you've gotten
all of the flags and ticked all the
right things
made all the right settings adjustments
you will have a perfectly functioning
Mac without anything lesser then in fact
you'll have a lot more than a regular
Mac will now a lot of people keep asking
me you know why would you do this why
would you install Mac OS 10 on such
high-end hardware well to be honest well
number one I'm not a gamer I've said
that about trading times but number two
I've gotten used to the Mac OS 10
environment but I'm not going to go into
it now expect a full video comparing a
Mac Pro to a hack Pro and this is what's
going to be I guess the finale of the
series I'm going to go ahead and show
what this machine is capable of what it
can do how powerful it is how much
faster it is your bang for your buck how
much you've paid for all the parts I'll
have all the parts links also down below
the more important links in the
description but essentially you're
getting a lot more for your money but
I'm not even gonna talk about it now I'm
just going to save it for part 5 that's
going to be the last video in the series
and it's probably going to be an
insanely long video too but thumbs up if
you're ready for that that is basically
what we're waiting for to wrap up this
hackintosh pro series and that's what's
going to be it that's what's going to
make this my daily driver I want to give
a shout out to yo man who wrote the very
detailed written instructions that I
have linked below and I also want to
give a shout out to Rob from CPU kid his
links will be below he took a lot of
time out of his day to help me also get
these ticks correct and help me get the
correct kernel flags to boot without
having to interrupt so now that
everything works I can thank those two
sources quite a bit for their help but
that's basically it guys thank you for
watching this extremely skeleton-like
video not very detailed but again those
links below are pure gold so anyway
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you guys in part 5 and I'll see you
later
bass
you